j'en ai rêvé toute ma
vie le trésor d'aujourd'hui qui n'a jamais été
trouvé
cinq milliards facile
oh mon dieu je suis tellement désolé
hé tu es toujours avec moi il y a
500 ans ma famille a trouvé la
fortune puis a été trahie
tellement de sang
presque sûr  il menace juste de
me tuer ne touche pas ton oreille comme ça
tu ressembles à un idiot inexploré
exclusivement dans les salles de cinéma
c'est le plus gros trésor qui n'a jamais
été trouvé
cinq milliards facile le 18 février ma
famille cherche cette personne
depuis très longtemps  temps tant de sang tom
holland
oh mon dieu préparez-vous à avoir un bon
accueil écossais
quoi
[Musique]
tom holland et mark wahlberg dans
uncharted nous ferions mieux de devenir plus petits dans votre
cas plus petits, ils ne sont qu'un pouce de plus que
moi, c'est un peu plus  que
ce gamin exclusivement au cinéma le
18 février
tu